le temps presse pour pierre paul
mythifié après trois ans dans son
logement il est forcé de partir dans
moins de 24 heures malgré ses démarches
impossible pour lui de trouver un
appartement cherche un logement c'est de
noël c'est il ne peut puiser des
démarches qui finissent plus chaka chaka
loi ce que je fais question voire
logements en plus du prix de la pénurie
de logement les locataires ont dû cette
année faire face à une autre embûche
lakovic 19 les règles sanitaires ont
empêché les visites pendant plusieurs
semaines ce qui laisse peu de temps à
bien des locataires pour trouver un
logement convenable et jérusalem ans
avaient scellé leur chemin au mois de
juin au 1er juin avec juste un mot je me
trouve un logement
ça donnait beaucoup de difficultés la
situation est particulièrement critique
cette année prévient le frapru qui dit
avoir reçu deux fois plus de demandes
aides que l'année dernière
l'organisme indique que 340 ménages
québécois n'ont pas signé de bail pour
le 1er juillet et ce nombre pourrait
atteindre 460 que le marché est
déconnecté de la réelle et d'un bon
nombre de ménages locataires venus
toujours plus élevés des logements
disponibles
on n'a pas vu aussi peu de logements
disponibles sur le marché depuis 15 ans
on fait le taux d'inoccupation des
logements locatifs est de 1,5 pour cent
à montréal c'est bien en dessous du taux
d' équilibre du marché qui est de 3% et
la situation est semblable dans les
autres grands centres urbains du pays où
ce taux est de 2 2% en moyenne
mais au delà des statistiques pour des
centaines de ménages l'avenir est
incertain
le fils municipal d'habitation de
montréal assure que des mesures sont
mises en place pour éviter que quiconque
n'est nulle part où aller demain déjà
qu'ils n'auront pas de logement demain
soit pourront temporairement habiter
chez de la famille ou des amis
ou sinon on peut regarder la possibilité
de l'hébergement temporaire une aide à
laquelle pierre paul mythifié aura
recours s'il ne signe pas un bail dans
les prochaines heures mais qui ne règle
pas son problème est qu'ils ne le
rassure pas sur ses chances de trouver
un logement ici riottier radio canada
montréal